this is the moment that the Embraer
aircraft jet came hurtling from the sky
in the tavir region north of Moscow
all 10 people including three crew
members were killed
Russia's Aviation agency has confirmed
that the Wagner military group boss
yevgeny burgosian was among the
passengers flying from Moscow to Saint
Petersburg local reports state two loud
bangs were heard and multiple videos
posted on social media appeared to show
the jet on fire
this flight radar map shows the moment
it disappeared
the remains of all 10 bodies have been
retrieved from the site and a criminal
investigation is underway
the main investigation department of the
investigative Committee of the Russian
Federation initiated a criminal case on
the fact of an aviation accident in the
TV region on the grounds of a crime
under article 263 of the criminal code
of the Russian Federation we're about
just two days before pagosian shared his
first video since his aborted Mutiny
against Russia's armed forces in June
Russian emergency services are looking
at two theories a possible explosion on
the plane and they are probing into the
Region's air defense systems loracan Al
Jazeera